- [Narrator] After weeks
of intense fighting,
resulting in battered
equipment and logistical issues
in the capital of Kyiv
and other northern cities,
Russian forces changed tack.
(Volodymyr speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] The Donbas region,
with flat countryside terrain,
is a more familiar battleground
for Russia's military,
which has trained a large portion
of its forces in open-air combat.
(gun booming)
And its landscape is more suited
to conventional battles,
involving artillery systems.
Moscow is estimated to have thousands
of tanks already deployed in the region
where Russian-led separatists
have been waging war since 2014.
- To a large degree, it is tank country.
That is you can really conduct
mechanized warfare operations
that is really the types of operations
that the Russian armed
forces traditionally
are quite good at.
- [Narrator] The move
comes after Russian forces
face several setbacks in
cities across the country.
Among the key issues, failing
to establish dominance
in the skies and not preparing
for stiff resistance
from Ukrainian fighters,
military experts say.
So as Russia shifts its
approach to focus on the east,
we analyze what went
wrong for Moscow in Kyiv
and why it believes it can succeed
in this next phase of war.
These images show a
convoy of Russian tanks,
infantry-fighting vehicles,
self-propelled artillery,
and logistical support heading toward Kyiv
in late February.
The column was thwarted by
Ukrainian resistance efforts
just days after Moscow began its invasion
of its smaller neighbor.
- Part of Russia's biggest failure
to take Kyiv was that
it stuck to the roads,
as military analysts say.
Satellite imagery showed
us these large columns,
long columns of tanks
and armored vehicles going
for kilometers and miles
on these roads.
And Ukraine did a really good job
of ambushing them from the forests
and from the sky with drones.
- [Narrator] Striking
the long supply lines
created logistical problems for Russia
as it tried to support its
forces inside the country.
- Russian forces at the
front were struggling
to get basic things like
even food and water,
let alone equipment.
- [Narrator] Early Russian
advances to take control
of the capital and other northern cities
were also hampered by poor tactics,
according to analysts.
- They haven't really trained
for it on a large scale.
The Russian armed forces
are essentially an
artillery army supported
by mechanized forces,
that is tanks and other armored vehicles.
So they always were short on infantry
because the way they fight,
they're not really meant to go
into cities and conduct
urban combat operations.
- [Narrator] That, paired
with an unexpectedly
resolute defense from
the Ukrainian forces,
armed with nimbler weapons,
including Turkish-made armed drones
and US-made javelins
left Russia vulnerable
in the city, and saw their
forces retreat in late March.
Russian officials have pushed back
against Western and Ukrainian claims
that it has failed.
- I don't think we failed, frankly.
We conduct our military
operation, it's not a war,
it's a military operation.
It has its own strategy,
it has its own aims.
- [Narrator] Russia's Defense Ministry
didn't immediately respond
to requests for comment
about their changing strategy in Kyiv
and the Donbas region.
Following failures to take Kyiv,
Russia refocused its strategy
to try to take control
of the Donbas region.
- Russia has been fighting a conflict
for eight years there already.
Pro-Russian separatists broke away
in two parts of the east,
Donetsk and Luhansk,
back in 2014 after Russia
seized Crimea from Ukraine.
- [Narrator] Military analysts
say controlling the region
and Mariupol could be key for connecting
what they describe as a land bridge
between the south of Ukraine and Russia.
- Uniting the east and
then southern front lines
of Russian forces,
I think it would make it easier also
to resupply the Russian
troops in the south.
- [Narrator] There are also
environmental factors at play.
In contrast to Kyiv, where
dense, urban wooded areas
proved difficult for Russian forces,
the Donbas region is more open,
which some analysts compare
to a World War II battlefield.
If it can coordinate its forces,
that could allow Russia to
leverage its military equipment.
- The situation is a bit more advantageous
for the Russian armed forces,
but, of course, there's also some deficits
and the Russians are running low
on precision-guided munitions.
- [Narrator] And Moscow
faces a protracted fight
with thousands of battle-hardened
forces in the region.
Analysts say Ukraine is believed
to have between 40 and 50,000
soldiers in the Donbas,
many of whom have spent years fighting
against Russian-backed separatists.
But a big factor in who
can control this next phase
of war analysts say is who
can achieve air superiority,
a key detail that has so far been hard
for open source investigators to track.
- You really would want
to dominate the skies
above your troops as they're advancing.
Make sure that no enemy
aircraft can attack your troops,
making sure that no enemy missiles
can hit your troops.
- [Narrator] For Ukraine
to be able to withstand
such attacks from Russia in the east,
keeping the flow of advanced weapons
from the US and other
countries is key analysts say.
Ukrainian president Volodymyr Zelenskyy
has demanded continued
assistance from allies
as the country enters a
different stage of war.
But despite Russia's
shifting military focus,
Putin's initial ambitions,
which Western officials said
were to take the capital
and install a new government
may remain missing.
(dramatic music)